so we begin with breaking news this hour
and reports that Ukrainian soldiers are
pushing into the southern city of
croissant that's after Moscow announced
it had pulled all of his troops out by
Friday morning it was the only Regional
capital Russia had seized in this war
Ukrainian soldiers have been seen
raising their flag but an official in
Horizon says many Russian troops remain
and have changed into civilian clothes
people outside the regional Capital have
welcomed Ukrainian soldiers Kiev says
its troops have retaken 12 Villages as
they move towards the city earlier a
major Bridge crossing the nipro river in
Hassan was destroyed by shelling this
was the only Crossing between the city
and the russian-controlled Eastern side
of the Nipper River
well we're in Russia and in Ukraine in a
moment we'll be getting the view from
Moscow in Mohammed Val but first to
assidbeg in clapaya in the Hassan region
so as that it does appear now like
Russian Ukrainian troops are beg your
pardon Ukrainian troops are in Hassan
City what can you tell us
well we haven't had any official
confirmation yet at least not from the
ukrainians that we have seen video on
social media with Ukrainian troops
marching through Villages and towns that
they've taken back being welcomed by
residents there waving Ukrainian flags
and hugging them and cheering them on
we've also seen video footage of
residents in her son raising the
Ukrainian flag on our administration
building as well as a police station but
but we haven't had official confirmation
now obviously you've just mentioned the
collapse of that bridge now the Russians
have Russians have blamed the ukrainians
but also they've been talking about
damage to one of the gates to that Dam
further up River again the Russians have
blamed blamed the ukrainians now
ukrainians have also been saying that
the Russians have destroyed
infrastructure in that city of Hassan in
terms of the sewers and television
station as well as other vital
infrastructure but we haven't had any
official confirmation but still the war
is not over the battle is not over we've
had officials say that some Russian
soldiers have changed into civilian
clothing and have taken up positions
inside the city of Carson the defense
minister has said there's still 40 000
Russian soldiers in the region of Hassan
and they continue to Target Ukrainian
troops as they advance from the east
side of that danipro River so yes the
ukrainians look like they are Marching
towards that City you haven't had any
official confirmation about them
actually taking it over but they're
still coming under Fire from Russian
forces all right acid thank you very
much and yes all eyes remain on this
strategic City let's take a closer look
at her son moscow's defense Ministry
says Russian troops have withdrawn from
the city moving across the Nipper River
they're now based on the Eastern side of
this natural geographical barrier here
let's bring in Muhammad Val in Moscow
Muhammad what is Russia's defense
Ministry saying about this that can only
be called a defeat
the spokesman of the ministry of Defense
he said that at 5 00 am this morning the
Russian troops completed their
withdrawal from her son and he said that
no Soldier was left behind no civilian
who wanted to move to the Eastern side
was also left behind no piece of
equipment was left behind and this is
very uh this is like a very different
situation from what happened in a former
Retreats or withdrawals at Russian
troops conducted during their you know
after the defeats they received in other
parts of North East and Ukraine so the
Russians at least can boast that they
have they've had an organized Retreat
from that area they know what they are
doing they are defending the lives of
their soldiers as they said and they
think this is a good strategy for the
moment but also they keep her son under
their gaze because it's not very far
from where they are stationing their
troops now only across the river and
they are capable of maintaining a
barrage of shelling on any location in
the city of Carson and around it and he
said
the spokesman of the ministry of Defense
he said that they kept the uh the
Ukrainian troops far from the city of
Carson about 30 to 40 kilometers away
and apparently Russia has this strategy
to keep that that area under bombardment
for for the future I'm Muhammad Val
reporting from Moscow thank you very
much